we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here's a viewer's opinion
about whether it's time for progressives
to just kill the bill because it's had
so much gutted this is the spending and
infrastructure bills that bernie sanders
discussed earlier in today's program
hey david i just finished listening to
your segment about the
now gutted
infrastructure bill and how
more and more is getting pulled out to
uh
appease joe manchin
and and others i'm with you i'm at the
point where i think that
progressives just need to say no there's
nothing in here for us we don't want it
better than that though i think what
should be done
if possible i don't know if it is but
bring it to a vote
bring it to the floor and
force mansion and force cinema to vote
no on it and then that way there's no
denying where
they are where anyone else is on
uh their position regarding this bill
and regarding
help for the american people who pay
their salaries yeah i'm not against
eventually just get a vote and if they
really aren't going to go anywhere get
them on record voting against it i'm
fine with that as i said i was fine with
it during the entire force the vote on
medicare thing that uh medicare for all
that aoc and uh
i'm not against getting people on record
i'm more about trying to actually
achieve something so i don't need to
immediately force a vote right now if
there's a chance that like for example
as bernie sanders said and we played the
clip earlier if he is still working on
getting prescription drug cost controls
in the bill i'd rather wait a little
longer and actually get that in the bill
and pass it because that's better for
more people um ultimately though i do
think that there has to be some kind of
limit and if we uh get to that limit and
progressives are better uh served by
just killing the bill
um at a certain point you got to just
vote and get joe manchin to vote no and
and get chris kirsten cinema to vote no
and get him on record i'm not against
that when the time comes it actually
does seem that at least bernie sanders
believes some substantive progress could
be made and some major things could be
put in the bill
we have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to talk about this just
completely botched uh revelation or
announcement from facebook that they are
changing its company name to meta
a lot of people misunderstanding
thinking facebook is now facebook the
app is now called meta no this is a
corporate change google is now alphabet
and it's still google.com everything's
still called google google nest google
home etc we will talk about um a
strawberry pop tart case
that is one of 400 lawsuits that a
lawyer has filed and when we talk about
frivolous
we've got to talk about this and i think
it'll be an interesting discussion and
then also outrage
over a southwest airlines pilot saying
let's go brandon which is the new
it's it's a
code for f joe biden that comes from a
sort of
confusion during a car race that took
place we'll explain it all but a
southwest airlines pilot essentially
saying f joe biden during his pre-flight
announcement
to passengers audible gasps were heard
in the cabin and demands for the pilot
to be fired he should be fired he should
be fired political statements um i
believe are against company policy for
pilots for basically every airline uh so
we will talk about that and much more
when producer pat joins me on today's
bonus show get instant access by signing
up at joinpackman.com